les états unis vont annoncer une
nouvelle aide militaire à l'ukraine 2 3
milliards de dollars celle enveloppe la
plus importante depuis le début de la
guerre kiev pour acquérir de nouvelles
armes ou encore financer des formations
des opérations l'argent provient d'un
fonds du pentagone les européens
prévoient aussi une aide supplémentaire
on retrouve justement à bruxelles notre
correspondant pierre bénazet pierre
bénazet bonjour cette enveloppe dead
américaine tout d'abord aux ukrainiens
est différent des précédentes pierre ont
effectivement parce que pour l'instant
la maison blanche j'utilisais un
mécanisme qui permet au président des
états unis dortmund ordonné le transfert
d'armement qui sont déjà présents dans
des stocks de l'armée américaine qui
sont relativement évidemment
considérable la dernière tranche d'aidé
américaine s'était 775 millions de
dollars qui avait pu être ainsi envoyé
vers l'ukraine en matière d'armement de
systèmes d'armes sur tous les systèmes
d'armes anti missiles et des six des
systèmes de missiles le champ de
bataille pour le combat rapproché
d'infanterie et antichars cette fois ci
c'est effectivement 3 milliards de
dollars c'est une nouvelle enveloppe se
font du pentagone est un fonds spécial
qui permettent de déclencher de manière
immédiate des opérations urgentes pour
des missions ou bien du transfert
d'armement ou de l'achat d'armement ce
qui va donc permettre à l'ukraine
d'acheter un petit peu comme ce qui
s'était passé pour les britanniques
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
d'acheter du matériel américain de
manière directe les européens aussi
effectivement ont des projets des deux
militaires on sait qu'il ya déjà eu
trois enveloppes d'admis milliards
d'euros pour l'union européenne destinée
à des achats en commun pour faveur de
l'ukraine l'allemagne elle annonce
qu'elle va développer débloquer un demi
milliard d'euros supplémentaires pour
des achats d'armements de la fourniture
de matériel militaire allemand à
l'ukraine pour cette année et pour début
2011 23 donc les européens continuent
leur aide militaire il ya aussi
évidemment des aides macroéconomique des
aides financières pour l'ukraine dont on
sait qu'elles réclament entre qu'elle a
besoin d'eux entre 12 et 16 milliards de
dollars et donc les européens qui ont
déjà prévu 9 milliards d'euros des deux
macroéconomiques devraient continuer
vrai continuer leur soutien économique
et financier dans la durée c'est en tout
cas ce que disent tous les responsables
européens ici merci pierre pierre
bénazet en direct de bruxelles